طبعا يعني انا هنا في هذه المنطقه بدات
منذ تقريبا نصف ساعه المسيره للعمال
المضربين عن العمل من مختلف القطاعات
بداوا من منطقه وهم متجهين الان الى مقر
الحكومه في اترك الصوره لتشاهد هذه
المسيره طبعا فيها يعني نقابات تابعه
لقطاع التعليم هناك نقابات تابعه للنقل
وايضا نرى نقابات تابعه لمختلف القطاعات
من همم الخدمه المدنيه طبعا هذا القطاع
الذي يضرب اليوم يشمل حوالي 100,000 موظف
وعامل من مختلف الدوائر الحكوميه حوالي ال
133 دائره ووكاله حكوميه منهم حفر السواحل
منهم حارس الحدود همم يعني همم الذين طبعا
يحل محلهم عناصر من الجيش طبعا هناك الى
جانب همم اضراب عمال الخدمه المدنيه هناك
اضراب للمعلمين هذا الاضراب هو الاكبر منذ
حوالي الثلاثه عقود يشارك فيه نحو ال
100,000 معلم همم ومن همم يعني المتوقع ان
يؤثر على حوالي 23,000 مدرسه في مختلف
انحاء انجلترا وويلز طبعا يعني نحن نعلم
بان ان النقابات تطالب رفع الاجور اا
يقولون بان ساعات العمل طويله الرواتب
بالكاد تكفي عشرات الالاف من هؤلاء بحسب
النقابات يعتمدون باته على بنوك الطعام
وبالتالي هم غير قادرين على تحمل تكاليف
واعباء الحكومه طبعا هذه المسيره التي
نراها تمتد لحوالي البضعه كيلومترات تتجه
نحو مقر الحكومه في تن داونز 3 من المتوقع
ان يكون هناك احتجاج لها هؤلاء مطالبه
الحكومه برفع الوجود نحن نع انا الحكومه
ملتزمه او يعني همم ملتزمه بموقفها همم
همم الذي يقول بانهم يعني بان الحكومه غير
قادره او لا لا يوجد المال الكافي لتحقيق
مطالب